كارثه العصر
يسعى بعضهم لرفع روح التضامن بين الناس
يسعون خلف مصالحهم السياسيه لتذهب مصالحكم
السياسيه الى الجحيم
نحن نسعى لتضميد هذه الجراح قولوا خيرا او
اصمتوا لا تقولون خيرا ولا تصمتون في الشر
هذا معيب
واكد هنا على نقطه اخرى لكل مواطنين
في الولايات المحافظات العشق في تركيا مع
اعمال الاخلاء
هنالك ما يزيد على سبعين الف شرطي وما
يزيد على 60 الف دركي من عناصر الجندرمه
المجموع 130 الف وايضا هناك خف السواحل
131 الف
الان هنالك الاجهزه
تحقق الامن الى المحافظات وحتى القرى
وتقوم بالنقل ودعم اللوجستي والتناقلي
هنالك جهود مستمده يقوم بها تقوم بهذه
الاجهزه الامنيه لكن اولئك المشوهين
والمحافظين طبعا ده يسعون في فتره شعبنا
اشد ما يكون في احاده الى الدعم العون
يحاولون تفرقه هذا الشعب وتشكيله هذه
التصورات المغلوطه نعيش هذا كله
ما من ذنب او جريمه ستموجود دون عقوبه
الان تم اعتقال العديد من الناس بسبب هذه
الاحداث التي ذكرتها هناك ميزه عليها
عشرين حادثه اعتقال جرت وكل حادثه
اصدقائنا يقومون باللازم بشانها
اصدقائنا يقومون بتامين المساكن والمخيمات
والطرق